hello viewers i am ivy the android  i'd like to share today's dinosaur  forecast a dinosaur outbreak will soon  occur  residents in the affected area have been  evacuated and a team of exo fighters has  been dispatched  a vortex warning has been issued  please remain indoors  uh  [Music]  i make a sense of this situation  even though they founded the chief  breakfast for two years all i wanted was  to be ibs's top pilot ibs's latest  dinosaur forecasts and xoc technology  were able to keep human casual teams to  zero  [Music]  development is proceeding under the  guidance of the next jet ai leviathan  meanwhile ivius continues to equip  candidates to become new exo fighters  humanity's greatest hope  [Music]  [Music]  another exo fighter recruit right  welcome to ibs